à une dizaine de kilomètres de kiev
quelle est la situation à l'heure
actuelle dans les rues vous sortez de
chez vous j'imagine qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire
écoutez moi je retrouve à la campagne
donc c'est un endroit voilà quand même
relativement quand on entend on a
entendu eu quelques quelques détonations
mais c'est très longtemps on s'est
déplacé ici hier soir pour mettre en
sécurité mes trois enfants dont trois
enfants justement puisque dans notre
bakiyev ça devenait ça commençait à
devenir une très dangereux on a bien vu
en par la suite que dans la nuit
certains bâtiments civils même été votée
victimes de bombardements ou des
missiles donc on est relativement bien
donc tant qu'il y ait pas de coupure
d'internet d'électricité et de l'eau
donc donc on est relativement bien mais
on reçoit bien sûr des messages de nos
amis de tous les arrondissements si vous
voulez de kiev et ça ça craint beaucoup
sacrant beaucoup puisqu'il ya des débats
des batailles dans dans dans plusieurs
arrondissements de kiev en ce moment la
situation est très dynamique ça change à
chaque instant donc difficile de la
presse est relayée par les médias donc
c'est difficile de dire à ce moment là
comment ça se termine on a justement là
vraiment aux besoins de de soutien en
fait les on a reçu l'information que les
forces
des armées ukrainiennes vont défendre
qui est aujourd'hui au chili l'actualité
comme comme comme les autres vous pensez
que les les ukrainiens vont prendre les
armes les ukrainiens de plus de 60 ans
ont été appelés par le ministre
ukrainien de la défense à prendre les
armes pour vaincre l'ennemi est ce que
vous pensez que c'est possible de
résister encore longtemps à la russie à
l'envahisseur
bah écoutez il ya déjà la défense
territoriale qui qui fait ce qu'il doit
faire pour l'instant donc voilà il ya un
bail à une stratégie de défense qui re
qui revient de l'armée ensuite donc bien
sûr il est nous allons y aura des gens
qui vont se battre après les civils vont
faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
sauvegarder leur vie en location dans
les souterrains donc je ne suis pas
difficile de prévoir quoi que ce soit
donc voilà posé le canon sais pas en
fait puisque on n'est pas à l'origine de
ce plan et on sait au fond peut pas dire
que la population civile était préparée
quand il plante un tel projet donc il y
a personne en ukraine tout aussi bien
qu'à françois halin loin qui une
expérience d'une guerre d'intérieur
pleure donc difficile de dire comment
les événements vont se ce procédé mais
c'est justement qu à ce moment là on a
besoin de calme on a besoin de
persévérer on a besoin de confiance dans
notre armée d'un autre défense
territoriale dans le pouvoir en place
quoi qu'il en soit et puis on a emmené
tous les espoirs aussi une grande partie
de l'espoir dans les efforts que la
communauté internationale puisse faire
en ce moment donc par les sanctions que
ça suive te voilà donc on peut discuter
que ce soit l'aide militaire que ce soit
la fermeture de ciel par les forces de
l'otan et c'est donc il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent être
appelés bien sûr au soutien de la
communauté internationale on l'entend
bien mais